okay let's see how much I can vote this
[Music]
all right first of all yes apologies
normally this would have been where the
next review for a black mirror episode
would have gone up but there was Doctor
Who news that means this getting bumped
back a day things will go back to normal
next week hopefully so you may or may
not have heard we had the premiere debut
thing for the new logo for Doctor Who
and some of you may be wondering is he
really gonna do a whole video about just
a logo and yeah I kind of am if more
people who you know follow subscribe to
me here also followed me on Twitter
maybe I could just post there that it's
a logo what do you want from me but
because I've only got a couple hundred
people who follow me on there as opposed
to the almost twelve thousand
subscribers that I have here if I don't
say something here I'm going to be
flooded with messages or comments saying
why haven't you talked about this what
are your thoughts on it so I just need
to I need to put it here so I'm not
getting pestered for it elsewhere
so yeah the logo the debut and whole new
look basically the third major redesign
on the sort of the look of the logo for
Doctor Who it seems like every new
showrunner has brought one in we had and
they've been tweaked sometimes during
you know Davies tweaked is a little less
time went along Moffat had his own and
now we've got this and overall I like it
I kind of like the vibe of it it's an
interesting contrast especially to
Moffat because Moffat went for like the
big blocky kind of letters a bit more
evocative of some of the old classic
versions of the logo in some ways which
was which was a you know neat for his
time but I think this is an interesting
way to go and there is something I like
how it's some things just don't quite
line up just slightly off it give us at
that slight air of mystery to it that
honestly I find intriguing I also like
the color scheme that's involved in the
you know the little tiny little 17
second however long it is video that the
BBC put up debuting the logo they also
released a still image which is honestly
just a really cool image and I like that
as well so now the real question how
much am I going to read into this
because if I wanted to I could really
stretch and talk about how you know the
maybe the more you know thin lettering
if things not lining up maybe that's
indicative of an increased level of
mystery and how we don't really know how
this doctors gonna go but I'd be pulling
that out of my butt I'm sure some people
are doing that anyway what I will note
is something that was initially pointed
out to me by some friends that I am in a
sort of a messenger group in where we
talk about Doctor Who that the logo if
you turn it 90 degrees that over there
on the oh that kind of becomes the
female symbol a gender symbol although
and it does look like people are
starting to catch on to that I'm gonna
go in a step further because since that
bottom bit is actually longer and like
goes outside what it would normally be
for the female symbol it's actually more
specifically the femme symbol which
would be for lesbians who identify as
feminists a butch so I find that
interesting so toss that out to me well
I guess the female symbol correct them
and say no with the femme symbol no you
know your stuff get it right and I don't
know whether I want to call this being
intentional or not because I could I
could make the argument either way like
part of me wants to go well look at the
overall look of the thing that's a way
to do it maybe they didn't notice maybe
they didn't think of it and I mean it's
not like it stands out massively I mean
once somebody points that out you it's
hard to not see it there but I you know
the way the whole logo flows it doesn't
really draw a ton of attention to itself
so it could have just been something
that happened once they settle on kind
of a font in general I've of the thing I
could buy that I could also buy that
they knew exactly what they were doing
and tilting it on the side was their way
to be slightly subversive and see what
they could get away with I could buy
either one of those and honestly for me
as far as I'm concerned it doesn't
really matter I know there are some fans
out there who will absolutely care and
demand to know was this done on purpose
or was this done by accident because it
will confirm or fight against the
inherent bias that they have about how
much of this is a
and pushing and as I know this this
thing is gonna start spreading that this
little nugget that I've now pointed out
and talked about I will be I would say
initially curious and probably
ultimately annoyed by how how certain
stripe a fan is really gonna go off on
one over this and look it's it's even if
you see that it makes you go oh there
general person makes you angry look
unless you've resolved to just never
watch the show again just calm yourself
down wash the dang thing don't get angry
before you've actually seen anything of
substance because we still haven't we
had we had like 40 seconds of her on
screen we've seen the outfit we've seen
this and that's literally it
it's not enough to get worked up about
so setting that aside you know coming
back to general thoughts on the logo I
it's new and I I tend to like new things
I can be prison or the moment sometimes
in that way but I will say that I I like
I said I like it in contrast to
Moffitt's I don't know if I like him
more than muffets I definitely like him
more than Davis I think the Davies is my
least favorite of the modern era Doctor
Who versions logo not least favorite
overall if you go to the 80s for the
really bad ones but you know the the
babies one never really worked for me
that was just kind of generic it didn't
feel like it I had a lot of personality
it was a little better when they got rid
of those dots took those off it but uh
you know Moffitt's I had more
personality I feel like there was a lot
of personality in this logo exactly what
is that personality conveying I like I
said I could hazard guesses but I'll be
more interested to come back and see it
again retro actively once I have a
better sense of what the show and Jodie
Whittaker and the part are gonna be like
so that I can look at this logo and get
a better sense of oh that's why it's
kind of more like this and I'll be
interested to find out but like I said
it's it's nice I like it it's it's a
fresh look but it's not so jarring with
what at least in my mind the sort of
things that work and Doctor Who that it
makes me go that just doesn't look right
which honestly in some ways was my
initial reaction to not
not the the title Isis I suppose but
that that logo that the DW and the
TARDIS it like when Moffat first debuted
that I was like yeah it grew on me over
time but even this like initial
impressions are better than they were
for that so yeah it this doesn't sway
any opinion that I had about one thing
or the other but I kind of like it it's
nifty so new Doctor Who logo do you have
thoughts on this are you annoyed with me
that I bumped my regularly scheduled
program to talk about something like
this I don't know whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's all that
stuff for you to do support me on
patreon buy a t-shirt follow me on
Twitter which I mentioned all those
things linked for all that stuff is down
below podcast etc etc so until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]